it's week 12's power rankings and we
we've done it like we have been over the
past three weeks where we put it out for
your questions and those questions help
frame the discussion but before we get
to the questions chris
some some significant moves because a
lot of the teams that were positioned in
the top 10
lost the bills bump up four spots simply
because
everyone in front of them lost this week
right the bills climb as high as anyone
other than the rams simply by not
playing because the dolphins and the
cardinals and the ravens and the
buccaneers all lost
i i i mean it's amazing um i remember
last week just going through social
media when you let up your power
rankings and there was a few you know
gentlemen who made comments like
you know there is no upper class this
year or there's no
legit you know upper class where it just
seems like
you know the steelers and chiefs have
kind of been in their own little
category and we've had the bucks flirt
and the seattle seahawks flirt with it
and you know they're still there on the
edge and of course the new orleans
saints who have now seemed to have
joined that group at least in my opinion
with the amount of games they've won in
a row the way it looks the way their
defense is playing but yeah it does seem
you know that i don't even upper middle
class is very interchangeable this year
and it is a small
group of real dominant teams if there is
even really a dominant team this year
you know in hindsight maybe i should
have made the rams for in the bills five
the last time we saw the bills they lost
right but the rams only won by three
points if it had been a more dominating
win if that fumble by tom brady had been
called a fumble as it should have been
and the rams had gone up by 14 and had
won by 10 or 14 points maybe they would
have been at number four maybe i should
have put them at number four i agree
with you that was probably the first
thing i jumped i mean you're probably
going back to like hey the bills did
beat the rams head-to-head
you know but at the same time yeah the
rams have played good football lately
and and you're right the last time we
saw the bills they lost that same
weekend the rams
you know convincingly beat the seattle
seahawks and russell wilson then go on
the road and beat tampa who we thought
you know got back on the right track
after their loss of the saints so yeah i
probably would have put uh the rams
ahead of the the bills but it's not like
egregious or crazy by any stretch of the
imagination
steelers are number one for the fifth
week in a row unbeaten at 10-0 the 18th
team in the super bowl era to pull that
off shield 1991 asks what does
pittsburgh have to do
to get the respect that a 10-0 team
deserves chris what do they have to do
well i mean i think you've hit on it a
lot you know first off how about not
need luck to beat the dallas cowboys
okay i mean you know it's games like
that
you know i i pittsburgh i know they have
not gotten the respect they quite
deserve there's no doubt for a 10-0
football team but you mentioned it and
laid it out yesterday it's not nearly as
dominant as we've seen other teams go
10-0
in the past you know yeah there was
it it's hey lamar jackson had the ball
on the four-yard line on the fourth and
one the chance to win the game you know
the tennessee titans that game the way
it looked of course and then yeah you
know the cowboys some of the
underwhelming houston and denver games
early in the year so i think all of that
you know let the philadelphia eagles
have a chance to win the game and tie it
at the very end to do those things i
think that's why it's not is like hey we
got a team that might be able to go 10-0
hey they're getting it done we like it
it's awesome i hear you you know most
people are getting on me because they're
like wait last year the the the the
steelers went eight and eight with you
know backup quarterbacks big ben should
be a top ten quarterback because they're
undefeated now listen if they just had
capable backups last year they're gonna
go the super bowl i mean the playoffs
they didn't
those weren't backups last year that's
what i want to tell pittsburgh that's
where it's like big ben's awesome but
last year you had third and fourth and
fifth stringers playing quarterback i'm
sorry i don't want to say it so yeah it
looks a lot better this year certainly
with big ben but they didn't need a
whole lot on the offensive side of the
ball to get them over the hunt hump
there but i think that's the reason mike
i think you've been all over it all
along
and i think one thing the steelers have
to do is beat the chiefs it's not their
fault the chiefs aren't on the schedule
during the regular season but that is
going to continue to linger until the
steelers beat the chiefs in the playoffs
even if they win every game between now
and then the steelers won't be regarded
as the best team in football and won't
it be strange if the steelers are 16-0
actually 17-0 meeting the chiefs in the
afc championship game and an underdog
underdogs
underdogs at home yeah two-point
underdogs at home to the chiefs that's
what it's going to be maybe two and a
half it could be now we know the
steelers their schedule um
is you know a little easier i don't know
if it's easier or not kansas city with
still has the bucks and the saints and
the miami dolphins on their schedule
that'll that'll be work there's no doubt
about that pittsburgh we know it's
baltimore this week uh buffalo in a few
weeks the cults after that those are the
teams you look at to go can they upset
their party a little bit you know i mean
yeah i'm not putting the ravens out of
contention tomorrow night i don't care
they're desperate you know that we see
the bills they're they're up there in
your power rankings and the cults are
damn good too so
uh
i would bet that they don't go
undefeated we see them slip off
somewhere here but it's still
nonetheless i'm not trying to disrespect
the steelers i'm very impressed and man
i root for him you know i've been a big
ben
uh defender and you know i've always
defended mike toblin so uh there's
really a part of me that that likes the
steelers and roots for him
the 1972 dolphins the only undefeated
team in the super bowl era 17-0 they
were actually slight underdogs in super
bowl seven and when you go back and look
were they really at yes to washington
they were slight underdogs they won 14
to seven should have been a shutout but
for guerrero upremian but uh and one of
the all-time great nfl highlights it was
worth it they still won and they got one
of the all-time great highlights as your
premium tries to throw a pass and throws
the ball up in the air ken bass grabs it
scores a touchdown only points to the
day for washington but if you go back
and look at their season week by week
the dolphins had plenty of close games
they had some blowouts too but they had
plenty of close games it tracks what the
steelers are doing a lot more than the
2007 patriots who just blew out everyone
especially early on until we got to
those last few games and every team was
giving them their best shot and that's
what the steelers are going to be facing
chris pointsbot has the steelers at plus
500 to go undefeated i would not take
that bet because when it's the bills
coming up in a couple of weeks on a
sunday night which is going to be an
awesome game when it's the colts on
december 27 in pittsburgh those two
games the teams are going to be bringing
everything they have to beat the
steelers and i just can't imagine them
checking off each of the next six boxes
which probably means they will but it's
not like they have a cake walk the rest
of the world no definitely not and we've
seen them like we've already talked
about struggle with some teams that were
clearly less than now i don't know maybe
the last two weeks you know the way they
handled the bangles the way they handled
jacksonville starts to formulate into
something like where hey i think we got
our we found our way on the offensive
side and you know the defense of course
still playing at a high level to maybe
where they start to dominate teams here
more
it's very impressive i understand their
fans being
you know
being or having the feeling of being
disrespected but i think you hit it
right where you know again not even all
the 10-0 teams or whether it was all the
peyton manning teams that we saw eight
8-9-0 and the tom brady teams and all of
that you know back to my dad's era his
90 team and joe montana and the 49ers
and those 90 teams you know yeah i just
usually when you see 10-0
there's six or seven games where you go
they dominated that game through and
through yeah they won by 14 or only one
by 10 but it was domination and then we
just haven't seen that all the way with
pittsburgh we've had moments of going
man what the hell why are they letting
this team hang around whoa they might
lose this to this team oh they made a
play to win it wow okay awesome so
that's where i think it's a little
different than most years
and that plays into their hands too you
don't get big headed and you continue to
have a chip on your shoulder because you
feel like people aren't respecting what
you've accomplished so you just keep
accomplishing it more and more chiefs
are still at number two king boss 261
wants to know how the defense can
improve and chris against the raiders 71
points surrendered in two games surely
there's room for improvement on that
side of the ball well there definitely
is no i mean that that's a team
you know one that matches up really well
with the kansas city chiefs you know i
think that's the big thing but they
their their secondary is has gotten
healthy you know that i look at that
chris jones he's been in and out of the
lineup here and there you know they're
not going to be a dominant dominant
defense that's you can't have it all
it's really it's impossible this day and
age in the nfl with the salary cap and
all of that
you know but they have a coach who's
creative he does the best with the
talent he's got available there i like
his formula it's feaster famine and they
have playmakers and that's really listen
we've seen
when they need to be tough and play a
certain way
they can do it
so i'm not worried about them we're
talking about i don't care what the
stats say the best offense in football
with mahomes and reed and those weapons
they're you give me an offense i'm
taking them and then okay all we need is
respectability out of the defense and
they have more than respectability you
know again they slowed down that 49ers
run game last year in the super bowl
they slowed down derek henry and the afc
championship game so they're game plan
specific there's been a few games where
they're asleep at the wheel things like
that but they got players they're
coached well and i'm i'm not concerned
about their unit overall i'm really not
three teams from the nfc west are in the
top 11 this week the rams are the
highest at number five seahawks creeping
up at number eight after beating the
cardinals who have fallen to number 11.
points bet has the odds for the nfc west
with the rams and seahawks both plus one
ten
arizona plus 380 san francisco the long
shot at plus 8 000.
ronald blake wants to know who's the
best team in the nfc west chris who
would you pick right now out of those
three i i guess at this second
i'd probably give the rams the slight
edge you know they had having them you
know having beat seattle two weeks ago
and then playing that game last week
you know i would give them the slight
edge i will say this
if seattle can continue to kind of play
defense the way they did last week
against kylo murray which was to me
you know um
it was tactically aggressive instead of
stupidly aggressive like we had seen
where it was just you know the weeks as
far as blitz
blitz blitz oh man they're throwing it
by us oh my gosh the guy broke the first
line of the line of scrimmage and he's
gone all those there was all these
issues last week they played a little
bit of like hey we're going to blitz
we're going to and they dropped out and
they dropped out and they did a great
job of containing kyla murray and were
more creative and had more diversity in
their coverages and then just blitzed
when they felt like hey this is a
situation we got a feel for what they're
going to do and all that i i liked what
i saw to seattle and then we saw the run
game really helps them so i don't know
how do you feel i'm giving the rams a
slight edge but like i don't feel real
real comfortable about that
i
i i want to see the rams and seahawks
one more time yes yeah i want to see one
more before i decide who the best team
is and we're going to see the rams and
the cardinals play twice not once over
the remainder of the season yeah kev dog
93 makes a point seahawks have a more
favorable next three games than the rams
before they play again does that give
seattle the edge in terms of winning the
division the seahawks have
the the eagles giants jets and
washington the rams have the 49ers
cardinals patriots and jets that's
an easier four-game stretch for the
seahawks who can get rolling again
definitely it really is i mean you know
really you look at any of those games
there and you just go none of those
teams should beat the seattle seahawks
they should not
might make it tough cool
all those things but the rams hey
it's it's the there's great familiarity
with the rams having to play the 49ers
this week who are coming off a bye week
and you know kyle shanahan ain't asleep
at the wheel and robert sala and they
know how to defend the rams and and
attack their defense so that's scary
this week right off the bat let alone
arizona and new england the weeks after
that so uh and then seattle and arizona
to end the year for the rams so they do
i mean you look at their schedule and
you go wow
you know four of their last five games
are legit and uh they're gonna have to
play good football to at least you know
come out in a favorable way there
through that stretch
and then there is
the nfc oh my god the
highest rated team
thank you there'll be some of that going
on tomorrow after multiple plates of
turkey at number 23 is the giants 24
washington 26 the eagles and 28 bringing
up the rear the team that i think may
actually pull its way into the front of
the line it's not a far trip to get
there the cowboys at 28. points bet
currently has it this way
eagles plus 175
cowboys plus 225 and washington and the
giants tied at plus 350. wow who do you
think the favorite is right now
i i have a hard time going with
philadelphia i just think there's more
you know the the play on the field is
not good
just the aura and feel around the team
the stress of the city with the way that
i just have a hard time thinking
philly's gonna be able to figure this
out i i don't know you know why because
you've said it and it's true the last
few years when they're in these
positions they seem to fight themselves
you know out of it but the cowboys i
think have the most potential for you
know they have some difference makers on
both sides of the ball
washington's interesting because their
defense and now the alex smith angle of
it because he's taking care of the
football they got a pretty good o line
antonio gibson can really run and terry
mclaurin's a superstar you know we don't
talk about him but he's a superstar that
you know just on a bad team that gets to
get lost in the shuffle so and then the
giants have played good football
i think
i i think i favor washington more than
anybody right now i do i just think with
the quarterback the run game and the
defense
i i i think they they pro they might
come out on top in this whole thing when
all said and done
i'm not going to pick one team but i'm
going to make a prediction yeah whoever
wins tomorrow wins the division you're
going to go without washington yeah
whoever wins that game they're going to
come out of that's a big spot 30 million
people are going to watch it or at least
30 million tvs are going to be on
whether you're watching or not is a
different issue but it's got that shine
it's got that feel it's got that glow
and i think that team is going to become
the favorite to win and likely will win
the division they're going to carry
something out of that in the final five
weeks so that's that's just my wild ass
guess because with this division who
knows giants have charged it so sorry as
i say giants have such a tough schedule
you know even though they're playing
football that's why i just couldn't i
couldn't go there now washington's
schedule is not very easy either that's
where it's it's this is not good
football teams with tough schedules down
the stretch that's where it's hard to
really like peg like who's gonna win or
do what or whatever else and uh i don't
know it's it's i can't believe the nfc's
what a horrible division this year i
still want to see how the giants are
after this mark colombo judge ugliness
from last week will it create an issue
in the locker room is joe judge looking
kind of funny at jason garrett who
brought colombo with him
to new york are there issues or is it
all resolved time will tell all right
the chargers at number 29 they were at
number 29 last week they got no bump for
beating the jets how dare you maximus
overdrive i get the chargers are now the
poster child of losing close games but
does that mean they're worthy of the
number 29 spot is anthony lynn really
the problem i mean
look around i mean where else would you
put the chargers we can pull it up chris
you tell me where else you would put the
chargers the number 29 based on the
teams that are in front of them yeah if
you have it no yeah i got it i'm here
i'm with you i don't know you're right i
don't it's hard to say
you know the cowboys
you know yeah okay maybe but you're
right i'm gonna take the lions over them
slightly the eagles the texans all of
them you're right i mean i have no
problem with that
you know
yeah the chargers
it's it's not great on defense special
teams is some of the poorest in football
and they find ways to mismanage games as
a coaching staff too
last week was like one of their best
jobs you've heard me say it i've been
yelling about it on the podcast the last
few weeks like stop the bullcrap we're
gonna play through the run the best
thing you got going on your team is the
number six pick in the draft who's a
superstar and already one of the ten
best quarterbacks in football and you
got keenan allen and mike williams and
hunter henry last week they finally
played through the pass game it was past
first oh wait they're crap scared of our
pass now we can run the ball just a
little bit or whatever but that that to
me you know with that quarterback i'm
excited about the chargers in their
future uh what i just question is i hope
anthony lynn can hang on and save his
job through this and and bear you know
bear the fruits of what justin herbert
can deliver into the future
and by the way i dropped the bengals
down to number 11 because of the injury
to joe burrow because without him they
have nothing and also i'm a little salty
about the fact that the bengals continue
to put him in harm's way and didn't do
enough to protect this guy who is the
future of the franchise the future is
now murky because of the serious knee
injury brandon allen will start at
quarterback reportedly for the bengals
this weekend not ryan finley who is the
game day replacement for borough and the
bengals also will bring in kevin hogan
and alex mcgooh mcgonig whatever i don't
know he won't make the team so we don't
need to learn how to pronounce his name
sorry alex's parents but uh
who are these guys why don't they bring
if they're gonna bring in this alex mc
whatever where's matt sims in all this
oh yeah
that's over sorry that ship has sailed
certainly but you know it's a little
concerning with finley
not not being named the starter or
playing you know he was
a mid-round draft pick two years ago a
guy that i thought had really a chance
to be successful one i'm certainly was
wrong with my quarterback evaluation on
him to where he got a chance last year
and it was not good and of course he
took over the game the other day and it
was not good so
uh you know when you're that kind of guy
mid-round draft pick you've had two
opportunities things don't go well man
you know that you could find your way
out of the league in a hurry in that
kind of scenario
i have been called many things many of
which i've deserved to be called one
thing i am is a realist and even though
it would make a ton of sense to see what
colin kaepernick could do
there's no way they're going to call him
it's over it's done that chapter is
closed but when when they're bringing in
guys for tryouts whose name i can't
pronounce because he hasn't been on my
radar screen since he was a
seventh-round pick of the seahawks in
2017 and never did anything anywhere and
is being pulled off the scrap heap for a
tryout it's hard not to think that a guy
who at one point by ron jaworski was
dubbed potentially the best of all time
in 2013.
how does that
i know how and i know why i know it's
just this is this is the latest brick in
that wall of what the hell is going on
here and we know what's going on yeah we
know what's going on it's over
i feel sad to say it i mean it really is
uh we know he got screwed over there's
no other way to say that too but yeah
the teams don't want to deal with it
it's been too long and uh i think that
ship has sailed
all right one more real quickly before
we break defense on wants to know which
team has moved the most this season i
need to pay this one off because
somebody actually and i assume it was
pete went back and looked to see what
the progression was oh well you know he
can't even count so we're gonna trust
him well that's true that's true i'm
waiting for one of these mistakes to go
in my favor but anyway the the
buccaneers have gone from six to ten to
seven to fifteen all the way up to four
currently at number 13. cardinals have
bounced around from 20 as high as six
browns have been as low as 32. i was mad
about how much browns were in week one
yeah but they've been as high as number
11. and the vikings have been
uh love me love me not 12 down to 30.
currently at number 18. but uh thanks
pete for doing something i never would
have done which is looking at more than
one week of the power rankings and
trying to figure out where they all fit
but you know for the most part we know
who the best teams are
there isn't a huge nucleus of them but
we know who they are after that who the
heck knows and it changes a lot in any
given week doesn't it yeah it does you
know and i i sit here because i like to
play this type of game at the end of the
year
you know we'll get to this point of the
year you start to go like you know out
of those teams that you got maybe in
your top 14 15. i mean how many of them
do we think can actually
go to the super bowl and win it like
right you got the bills at number four i
understand that i'm not trying to push
back against that but i just i get
interested in like do i really think the
bills could go to a super bowl can they
win a game or two in the playoffs i
think so but i don't know if i look at
them as super bowl caliber
where i think teams like the rams behind
them have a little bit more of a super
bowl caliber
type team than the bills do you know so
i think that's always an interesting
exercise as i look at it here because
yeah the dolphins of cardinals those are
two teams i look at and go yeah i get
where they're ranked i understand that i
don't think they're legit super bowl
contenders in a year like this like just
look at it quickly mike
like
how many do you think are there your top
three sure
you know do you put the colts in that
category
would you do that would you put them in
this i think i think
i i think the colts uh
they they on any given sunday they could
beat anyone if they have things fall
their way so yes yeah okay i would with
that defense they're getting a lot off
this line i get it you know i think we
both look at the packers as seahawks the
super bowl worthy the titans is super
bowl worthy yeah the dolphins of
cardinals i don't feel that way the
ravens i don't think the packers are i
don't think the packers are you don't
think they are either
i think the packers are going to step
into a buzz saw before they get to the
super bowl just like last year i could
see that i could see the only way i l
the packers to me are a team that the
the matchups have to fall right that's
how i kind of look at it in some ways to
where maybe if they got a
uh
you know wild card game
they can win
you know
whoever that is you know they play
seattle or tampa or arizona roger's
gonna be able to throw the ball in those
groups and you know who knows what
happens but yeah they need an
unfavorable matchup i think in the next
rounds and you're right i don't know if
that happens there i'm not going to
count them out i'm going to keep them in
the super bowl contender list but i i
don't feel real strong about it like you
yeah i i think well i look we love
compelling story lines we love upsets i
want steelers chiefs in the afc
championship game and as of right now i
would sign on for saints rams rematch of
the non-call of pass interference in the
nfc championship in new orleans let's
bring them all back let's do it again
saints fans wanted a do-over they may
get a do-over under
pretty different circumstances but with
a lot of the same people involved
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports